Hola que tal ? (Salut comment ça va ?)
Aujourd'hui on est sur "It's Always Monday"
C'est un petit jeu indé gratuit (qui a l'air un peu psychologique aussi),
C'est l'histoire d'un mec qui est au travail
Qui s'appelle Bob et il travaille dans un bureau comme ça
Et euh... euh... J'ai aucune info de plus donc on va découvrir ensemble *rire*
Chaque fois j'balance des explications mais j'ai pas d'info ça sert rien
Des fois j'ai l'impression que toute ma vie je dormais avec les yeux à moitié ouverts
Un gros coup de vent me donne l'impression que quelque chose va changer
Donc je crois que c'est un gars qui travaille dans un bureau. Tout le temps. Tous les jours.
Et il a la même routine etc..
5 étapes de plus et tu seras libre
Hmm Strange. Oui, oui !
Qui a mis ça ? Qui est le psychopathe qui a mis ça ?
J'ai mon pc. Je peux travailler ou aller sur Chatroulette
*mouvement de bouche*
"Hey Bob, comment ça va ?"
"T'es toujours coincé dans cet endroit ?"
De quoi tu parles ?
"De quoi tu parles ?"
"Je suis en chaleur." *rire niais*
"T'as toujours un copain ?"
Pourquoi il a marqué autre chose?
Il a commencé à écrire : "T'as toujours un copain" puis il a arrêté il a marqué "Oublie ça."
Et la personne lui repond: "Bob je peux te voir agoniser"
J't'envoie un fichier. Ouvre-le si tu veux sortir de cet endroit.
Qu'est-ce que c'est? Ouuuuuuh attends !
Attends ! ATTENDS ! Ca va trop vite entre nous !
Ohh press h to hide.
C'est ce que je fais !? Non non mais, j'appuie sur h!
Il va me virer. Il va me virer le con. Ca marche pas
Bah j'suis viré. Bien sûr j'appuie sur "h" et l'autre il regarde mon écran
Y'a une meuf qu'est comme ça !
Il travaille monsieur ! Putain ! 4 étapes et tu seras libre ...
On en a fait 1 ! On en a fait une ! Se faire prendre par son boss en train de matter des photos de fille sur Tinder !
Ne faites pas ça ! Je vous jure ça ne va pas du tout vous ammener la liberté
Ca va vous ammener que des emmerdes !
Ok allez on va travailler... Oh putain il fait du Excel
*rire niais* Ohh nan.. Oh.. Oh c'est horrible
Euh ...Je peux éteindre le pc ?
Oh oui !
Alors, qu'est-ce que ? qu'est-ce que j'ai à faire ?
Est-ce que j'ai des potos ?
Est-ce que j'ai un collègue ?
Bah oui j'ai un collègue, il s'appelle Bob aussi !
On est tous Bob c'est ça la blague ?
En mode tous les mêmes, voilà c'est ça on s'appelle tous Bob, tous les mêmes.
J'ai compris la métaphore !
Parle à Bob2 il a toujours des bonnes idées
Bob2, qui est Bob2 ?
Qui est Bob2 ici ?
Bob, Bob, Bob
Bob
Bob 2 ! il est là !
Et il s'amuse à lancer des boulettes de papier dans la corbeille
Et il y arrive très très bien !
Bob2 t'as une idée pour moi ?
Amène moi les burikas qui sont dans la cuisine et je t'aiderai à t'échapper
Mais bien sûr Bob2 !
Lui par contre le boss il dit rien !
Comme au lycée, qui c'est qui prend ?
C'est Bob !
C'est jamais Bob2 !
Where is the kitchen ?
C'est très glauque cette boite, très épurée
Euuuh..
Mais très glauque
En mode les gens sont tous les mêmes quoi !
Ils font tous la même chose, ils ont tous le même PC, le même bureau, la même gueule.
Alors c'est quoi les burikas ? C'est ça ? Oui !
Alors j'ai tes burikas Bob2 tu vas m'aider à m'enfuir mon gars
Tiens mon gars, les burikas
Oh t'as une clé, c'est pour moi ? "Come on, take the key !!" Ok !
Ca ouvre quoi ? Ca ouvre euh..
Un bureau secret ?
Aaah, c'est ça regardez. "Exit"
J'peux ouvrir le locker ?
Oooh, attend parce qu'on peut explorer, on a pas exploré
Un autre bureau. Mais Bob est absent !
Bob est absent, l'patron il dit rien !
Mais mec faut qu'on défonce le patron, faut qu'on aille le voir hein !
Mec, Bob est absent tu dis rien !
"N'entre pas dans mon bureau ! Retourne travailler esclave !"
Il sait pas euh.. Qui on est !
*rire* .. "Employé du mois: Bob"
Elle est drôle cette vanne
Alors, où nous mène donc cette porte de sortie ? C'est ça la question
Dans le.. Dans l'espace fumeur, c'est ça ? Avec d'autres Bob ?
"Open the door"
Ooooh, attend c'est agréable de travailler dans c't'endroit quand même !
Attend on va s'isoler sur le petit ilot
attend c'est génial d'avoir ça au travail
On va s'assoir je suppose ouais on s'assoit
on va contempler (euh) ce merveilleux arbre
C'est très très beau avec cette petite fleur qui tombe
Ah...
transition
3 trucs de plus à faire et on sera libre
je pense qu'il faut casser les... au patron
à mon avis il faut forcer auprès du patron
et je me demande ce qu'ils veulent dire quand ils disent qu'on sera libre, qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent dire, mon gars?
C'est ça la question!
J'peux pas l'défoncer?
Y a pas moyen qu'je le défonce?
Je pète ce livre sur son crane chauve là!
HEIN!
Imbécile!
Ou alors, ah, j'peux pas lui tirer la chaise?
Tu sais, la meilleure blague du monde!
En fait, j'aurais pas dû jouer à ce jeu aujourd'hui, j'suis d'humeur à faire n'importe quoi, et je joue à un jeu très poétique!
En plus on a déjà eu du poétique avec "The Last Guardians"!
Ah! On peut s'asseoir et écrire, c'est ça?
On va faire un origami!
Oh!
Ca part sur un avion ça!
Wouaaah!
Alors, si je peux me permettre, la feuille elle fait pas ça en vrai!
Il a fait quoi? Il a fait un poisson!
"Peut-être que ça pourra rendre quelqu'un heureux"
Oh il est mignooon! Il est mignon Bob!
Qui a des origamis, y a peut-être un mec qui a des origamis sur son bureau?
Et je vais devoir deviner qui c'est, pour lui offrir ce merveilleux poisson...
euuuh, en feuille!
Aaah mais là regardez!
Y a une pièce que j'avais pas vue! Bah c'est elle!
Oh non son poisson est mort!
Oh non ma pauvre!
"Est-ce que tu peux me trouver un poisson différent?"
Bah j'ai exactement ce qu'il te faut!
Il a des petits poumons en papier! En feuille à petits carreaux, tiens!
J'te le mets là?
Ouais! Ca a marché!
2! Deux trucs à faire!
Ce jeu est passionnant mon gars! Par contre j'comprends toujours pas pourquoi il a pas rejoint la fille du début!
Mais bon! Euuuh! C'est Bob! C'est Bob, il est touchant!
C'est un homme touchant, c'est un homme brave!
Quand j'vois ça j'me dis que j'ai vraiment de la chance d'être YouTubeur, !
Qu'est-ce que j'aimerais pas bosser dans un bureau!
Y a plein de gens qui le font! Et ils sont très courageux, bien plus courageux que moi, qui fait mes vidéos!
Oh! Ici il y a des casiers!
"Sol"
Y a rien dans les tiroirs, nan, mais ça fait de la musique
donc je pense qu'on va devoir trouver une partition quelque part!
Et faire de la zik!
Peut-être dans ce bureau-là?
Ah regardez, y a un casier! C'est fermé!
Faut trouver une clef?
"Do not open"
Avec la clef! Parfait!
On ouvre...
Oh! What the fuck!
C'est glauque!
On est surveillés de ouf en fait!
Oh !
Oh what the !
OH!
Tieenns!
J'l'ai giflé! C'est un réflexe naturel!
Attends le mec il a un sixième sens du !
Il sent quand quelqu'un touche aux caméras qui espionnent les gens, d'accord!
"1 étape de plus et tu seras libre"
Ah! J'entends du vent!
Y a plus aucun Bob!
Plus aucun Bob!
What the fuuuck!
Mais non!
Il va se suicider?
Comme si la liberté, finalement, c'était de mettre fin à sa vie!
Mais non!
Mais si, mec, j'crois qu'c'est ça...
"Freedom"
Eeeeh bé! Un jeu très, euh, qui fait réfléchir!
Qui fait bein réfléchir!
Moi, j'avoue, dès que j'ai eu mon bac, je me suis consacré à YouTube à plein temps, donc j'peux pas... J'ai pas connu un métier...
euh, plus traditionnel!
J'sais pas moi, caissier, travailler dans un Fast-food,
travailler dans un bureau, être euh... J'en sais rien!
Peu importe ton métier, peu importe ta vie, t'as une routine qui s'installe et faut juste savoir la mouvementer un p'tit peu, savoir,... Trouver quoi faire!
J'sais pas, avoir une passion, par exemple moi c'est les jeux vidéos, y en a ça peut être la flûte
euh, j'en sais rien!
C'est ce qui te fait kiffer! C'est ce à quoi tu penses quand tu fais ta p'tite routine qui t'emmerde un peu,
tu penses au truc cool que tu vas faire derrière et t'arrives à passer au-delà!
Eh ben là non! Le gars, pour lui, la liberté c'est de se suicider, voilà...
C'est... Non! Ca c'est non! Ca je dis non!
Bref, c'est encore un jeu qui me fait me rendre compte à quel point j'ai de la chance!
Mais qui me fait aussi me rendre compte qu'il ya des gens qui vivent ça,
qui se sentent très très mal parce qu'ils ont une vie très,
qui se répète, une sale routine qui les fait chier, ils arrivent à pas en sortir, y a rien de nouveau, rien les fait kiffer...
Faites-vous kiffer les gens!
J'en sais rien, aujourd'hui y a dix mille moyens de kiffer, de se divertir, d'apprendre des choses, surtout avec Internet!
Alors foncez! Demain, j'veux que l'un de vous sache jouer de la flûte de ouf et me fasse un morceau!
*rire*
Bah merci d'avoir regardé, n'hésitez pas à mettre un pouce bleu!
J'aime bien, j'aime bien, j'aime bien les p'tits jeux comme ça qui font réfléchir, qui sont assez psychologiques!
Et vous avez l'air d'aimer ça aussi donc ça me fait très plaisir!
Ca prouve finalement qu'on a grandi tous ensemble!
Qu'on mûri! C'est beau!
C'est vrai! J'suis sûr que si j'avais fait ce jeu y a quatre ans, les gens auraient pas kiffé quoi!
Et même moi j'aurais pas kiffé!
Allez à bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo, merci d'avoir regardé portez-vous bien, ciao tout le monde!
Putain il m'a flingué! J'avais de l'énergie!
Je sortais des vannes et là il m'a... Il m'fait réfléchir de ouf le jeu!
Aller on fini tous la journée comme sur son siège, à très vite!
C'est long!
(Sincèrement, si vous avez des pensées suicidaires, n'hésitez pas à demander de l'aide, ce n'est pas une faiblesse, des gens savent comment vous aider)
(Vous n'êtes pas seuls! Des gens sont là pour vous, vous ne le savez juste pas encore!
Bisous, je vous aime tous!)